[Musique]
à l'origine de chaque entreprise de la
construction chaque entreprise il ya une
petite étincelle une petite étincelle
qui éclaire un noyau d'entrepreneurs
fond d'un garage qui sont en train de
refaire le monde
il crée les invente un nouveau procès d
un nouveau produit une nouvelle manière
d'attaquer à marcher en amour ils
innovent et que vous vous appeliez bill
gates james dyson henry ford ou plus
modestement pierre snow dinos c'est
juste une expérience de vie incroyable
on peut il ya un plaisir quasi palpable
et vous êtes gorgées d'une énergie qui
va booster incroyablement votre création
d'entreprise le problème c'est que cette
petite étincelle
elle se déploie pas dans l'organisation
elle va pas toucher l'ensemble des
salariés quand l'entreprise se développe
alors l'entreprise continue malgré tout
à aa innover mais elle le fait de
manière différente
elle investit dans des start up elle
rachète d'autres cabinets et mon sujet
il est là il exactement à cet endroit là
il est comment faire pour que cette
petite étincelle se propage dans
l'organisation et puisse toucher
l'ensemble des collaborateurs
alors ma réponse à cette question c'est
qu'il faut ce qu'elle ait l'intention et
la culture est pas le produit ce qu'elle
est ça veut dire déployer multiplier
alors pour comprendre ce que je veux
dire à travers ça on va ensemble ce soir
créer une entreprise une entreprise de
restauration et on va regarder son
développement sur les deux possibilités
imaginez qu'on soit trois copains on se
connaît depuis très longtemps on est
passionné passionnée de cuisine
passionné de bio et passionné de cycle
court on aime bien parler directement au
producteur est notre cas nous c'est quoi
c'est de rendre le bon accessible à
toutes les bourses
et on a envie de créer un restaurant
alors régulièrement on se réunit chez
les uns chez les autres et puis on on
essaye de trouver la recette qui va
incarner notre restaurant et puis un
soir il ya l'un de nous trois
max qui arrivent ils arrivent avec un
burger et nous le fait goûter et l'a
instantanément
on sait qu'on a trouvé le on a trouvé la
recette on a trouvé le produit
son truc est incroyable derrière tout
est facile on trouve le nom c max qui a
amené le produit donc on appelle ça big
max il voyait aucune allusion on trouve
notre base line qui est le meilleur
burger au meilleur prix cohérente avec
notre intention et on s'installe à
grenoble et instantanément le bouche à
oreille fonctionnant et à la queue
devant le magasin
c'est un succès foudroyant tellement
foudroyant et un fonds d'investissement
qui vient de voir et qui nous dit mais
votre truc c'est génial je vais vous
aider à le déployer et nous on y va
évidemment oui
et donc nous la partie à recruter des
équipes à paris à madrid à new york
athènes et puis à chaque fois il se
passe la même chose on arrive on leur
fait goûter notre orgueil et ensuite on
leur explique très précisément comment
ce burger est fabriqué de manière à ce
qu'ils répliquent très précisément la
recette et que l'expérience client soit
la même partout et ça fonctionne
l'entreprise se développe on gagne de
l'argent c'est une modalité
développement qui est qui à la fois
rassurante mais qui est performante
moi j'ai juste de soucis avec ce modèle
là
le premier souci c'est que quitte à
recruter des gens pour exécuter auto
prendre des robots ma conviction c'est
que ce qui fait un humain c'est sa
capacité à créer c'est pas sa capacité à
exécuter et puis la deuxième chose c'est
que quand tu es à new york
j'aime bien grenoble mais j'ai pas envie
de manger la même chose que quand tu es
à grenoble alors regardons un peu ce que
le deuxième business modèle serait
capable de nous proposer par rapport à
ces deux contraintes
ça démarrait pareil on va recruter des
gens sauf que cette fois ci au lieu de
les recruter sur leur capacité à
exécuter
on va recruter des gens qui ont la même
passion prix des gens qui sont
passionnés cuisine passionné de de bioux
passionnés circuits courts des gens qui
ont la même préoccupation que nous qui
est de rendre le bon accessible à toutes
les bourses
et puis des gens qu'on va vite créer un
restaurant et on leur présentera notre
burger mais non pas pour qu'il le copie
pour qu'ils s'en inspirent
et à partir de là vous comprenez bien
qu'on aura autant de burgers différents
que l'équipe donc on n'est pas loin de
la solution puisque finalement on a
réussi à propager l'étincelle puisqu'on
a réussi à faire vivre la même
expérience à toutes les équipes
la même expérience que celle que les
fondateurs ont vu et on est tous une
communauté alignés sur une intention
commune mais l'entreprise qu'on a créé
elle est drôlement singulière puisque
quand on y réfléchit deux minutes c'est
quand même la première entreprise qui ne
vont pas qui ne vend jamais le même
produit je vais leur dire parce que
j'adore cette phrase c'est la première
enseigne qui ne vend jamais le même
produit
c'est juste un concept moi qui m'excite
beaucoup et j'ai envie d'explorer plus
profondément et si on regarde un petit
peu plus profondément ce modèle
finalement on voit qu'il a trois
caractéristiques intéressantes autour de
l'innovation du marketing et de son
impact sur l'humain sur ses salariés
alors on comprend rapidement qu'au
niveau de l'innovation c'est juste une
machine incroyable
et puis c'est une machine qui a la
particularité d'être organique c'est à
dire que c'est les salariés qui créent
et qui innove c'est pas une innovation
qu'on va chercher à l'extérieur de
l'entreprise
donc ça ça lui donne une grande solidité
et puis c'est une innovation qui est
quasi infini pour une première raison
qui est que votre territoire
d'innovation c'est votre mission et
notre mission c'est le meilleur burger
au meilleur prix il suffit de la changer
pour réouvrir un nouveau terrain
d'innovation la meilleure salade au
meilleur prix le bon meilleur prix et là
on ouvre de nouveaux territoires
d'innovation possible est la vraie
raison pour laquelle c'est vraiment
inépuisable comme innovation c'est que
ça s'appuie sur la diversité des humains
ça s'appuie sur la singularité de chacun
la singularité vous savez c est ce qu
est à l'intersection de votre patrimoine
génétique de votre culture et de votre
éducation et ça fait chacun d'entre nous
ici une personne unique et donc
l'innovation qui s'appuient là-dessus
sera forcément inépuisable alors quand
on parle innovation
le marketing est pas très loin et oups
on n'a pas fait d'études marketing
on a juste fait l' inverse
traditionnellement marketing leur ait
consisté à quoi il aurait consisté à
prendre un panel à l'étudier et a
fabriqué le produit qu'on imagine que ce
panel va désir est là on n'a pas du tout
fait ça on a créé un produit que nous
aimions et ensuite on a vérifié qu'il y
avait un marché
on a juste fait complètement l' inverse
s qui sous tend cette démarche c'est le
fait qu'on a la conviction que l'humain
est le meilleur capteur des tendances et
qu'on fait confiance à son intuition
alors c'est quelque chose qui est
discutable largement discutable en
revanche j'ai beau réfléchir
je me dis qu'il ya pas une étude
marketing où il n'y a pas une analyse de
big data qui va me conseiller d'aller
challenge et accor en créant airbnb
c'est trop peu rationnel il ya quinze
humain qui peut penser quelque chose
comme ça donc humain il est au coeur de
notre dispositif et on va regarder là la
dernière catégorie pour regarder ce que
notre modèle donne par rapport à à cet
humain et pour faire ce slide on a
hésité entre le terme d'humains et le
terme de salariés finalement on a retenu
humain mais on a compris que c'était
précisément dans cette contradiction se
posait le problème on va pas se le
cacher il ya une vraie difficulté
aujourd'hui dans les entreprises
morales pour arriver à capter les
talents qui sortent de cette
merveilleuse école est d'arriver à les
faire rester dans l'entreprise sade ya
quelque chose de chronique est quelque
chose qui est de plus en plus
problématique
et c'est quelque chose qui se comprend
quand on prend un peu de recul parce que
finalement l'intention d'une vie c'est
quoi c'est d'être heureux et c'est
d'arriver à s'épanouir pour être heureux
et il ya une forme de déséquilibre entre
l'importance de cette intention
personnel et le temps arithmétiquement
qu'on y consacre pendant notre vie
active
si vous enlevez sommeil pendant votre
vie active ou passer 40% de votre temps
dans l'entreprise
je vais pas faire un sondage mais je
suis persuadé que ce temps là n'est pas
exclusivement consacré à votre
épanouissement
mais plus probablement à maximiser du
profit quelque part donc là on a un
déséquilibre qui c'est qui est de plus
en plus conscientisés et qui fait
qu'effectivement les grandes entreprises
ont du mal à recruter alors comment
notre modèle il réagit par rapport à ça
un autre modèle il est pas mal parce que
déjà ils proposent du sens rendre le bon
accessible à tous et puis propose une
communauté et enfin il met entre les
mains de tous les salariés
l'activité qui est probablement la plus
épanouissante qu'ils soient qu'est la
création celle qui est naturellement
réservée aux artistes aux entrepreneurs
là où à l'extérieur de l'entreprise
là
on l'amène dans l'entreprise ce qui fait
que le paradigme vie perso vie pro s'en
trouve complètement chamboulé c'est plus
le sujet le sujet c'est ou est-ce que je
pratique des activités qui vont
m'épanouir en tant qu'humain alors c'est
pas le seul paradigme qui est chamboulée
par notre approche
il y en a un autre c'est le financier
j'ai pas s'il ya des directeurs
financiers dans la salle mais en tout
cas quand on va aller voir notre fonds
d'investissement pour se déployer à
l'international et qu'on va lui
expliquer qu'on va créer une filiale à
new york et qu'on va lui dire on sait
pas quel produit on va vendre et on sait
pas quand est-ce qu'on aura le produit
moi je dis ça mais je suis à peu près
convaincu que son lapin qui va nous
suivre
donc j'ai pas la réponse à cette
question
on n'est pas encore assez avancé sur ce
type d'organisation pour trouver la
réponse à cette question
en revanche j'ai deux convictions la
première c'est que je ne peux pas
imaginer une seule seconde
autant d'innovations ne se concrétise
pas à un moment donné dans des succès
commerciaux et du cash
ça c'est la première conviction et la
deuxième conviction elle et que je pense
que on a toujours intérêt à s'aligner à
rester proche de son adn et a travaillé
sa singularité c'est vrai pour un
individu mais c'est encore plus vrai
dans une entreprise
un seul exemple pendant la crise qu'a
traversée la presse écrite avec
l'arrivée du digital il ya un journal
qui a traversé sa de manière sereine
c'est le canard enchaîné qui a toujours
été profitable et qu'encore profitable
aujourd'hui il est resté parfaitement
alignés sur son attention
alors si on a des difficultés de
financement il ya quand même une bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'au début de l'histoire
c'est à dire que cette entreprise que je
suis en train de vous décrire et
d'essayer de vous de vous faire imaginer
elle existe déjà un petit peu il ya déjà
des signaux faibles qui montrent que l
est déjà parmi nous le premier c'est au
tour du recrutement il ya beaucoup
d'entreprises qui aujourd'hui affiche
l'élément culturel comme étant un
critère essentiel voire principal dans
le recrutement
prenez une entreprise comme airbnb
airbnb ne passe jamais d'annonce ne
prend que les candidatures spontanées et
pendant le processus de recrutement il
ya un entretien qui est dédié à vérifier
l'alignement culturel du candidat avec
l'entreprise et cet entretien il a lieu
tous les ans on toute votre vie chère
bienne be un autre exemple plus récent
dans le sport avec l'équipe de france et
avec des chants deschamps a pas été
chercher le meilleur technicien à ce
poste là il a pris le technicien qui
était capable de se marier avec la
culture qu'il était en train de
construire et d'accepter le collectif et
l'intention on a vu le résultat
il ya un autre sujet qui bouge beaucoup
aujourd'hui dans les entreprises c'est
le management il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
choses qui se passent autour de
l'innovation managériale et en
particulier une chose autour du
management par le pourquoi versus le
management par le comment
rapidement le management par le
commencer si demain vous avez un
collaborateur a envoyé à marseille
vous allez lui procès c'est complètement
la chose en vison tu prends telle
voiture tu passes par telle route tu
t'arrêtes at-elle stations d'autoroutes
pour faire le plein et pour manger et
vous allez comme ça lui indiquer tout ce
qu'il a à faire jusqu'à son arrivée à
marseille
là vous êtes dans le management par le
comment le management par le pourquoi ce
serait déjà lui expliquer pourquoi il
doit aller à marseille et ensuite de lui
donner un cadre et non pas un process
vient aulas tu as un budget de 50 euros
et tu dois y être avant demain 10h hélas
si on travaille comme ça on va vite se
rendre compte que trois collaborateurs
auront trois solutions différentes pour
aller à marseille en respectant les
contraintes et l'intention
alors le fait que ça bouge comme ça dans
les organisations
c'est super rassurant je sais pas vous
mais moi c'est quelque chose qui me
rassure terriblement parce qu'on est
quand même en train de parler d'un sujet
nous on est encore en train de parler de
l'épanouissement individuel et de
l'entreprise et on est en train de
donner une visée plus humaniste à
l'entreprise c'est pas rien donc est ce
qu'il faut retenir de tout ça c'est
quand ce qu'ils ont l'intention et la
culture et non pas le produit on est
arrivé à propager notre petit et à celle
on a permis à la singularité de chacun
de s'exprimer et on a créé des
entreprises plus innovantes plus
épanouissante et beaucoup plus
singulières et moi ça me rassure
terriblement parce que j'ai deux crac
la première c'est qu'avec la
mondialisation et le digital qui vient
amplifier ce phénomène là on parle tous
anglais on mange tous la même chose on
lit tous les lisent tous les mêmes brève
et on est tous le même téléphone sa
ventouse ya ce même pas et ma deuxième
crainte elle est ou plutôt un espoir
le fait d'accéder à sa singularité
le fait de pouvoir l'identifier
l'accepter et la vivre c'est juste une
chance énorme c'est quasiment le chemin
d'une vie et ça je voudrais que ce soit
accessible au plus grand nombre
pas simplement à ceux qui osent franchir
la barrière devenir artiste ou
entrepreneurs mais que tout le monde
puisse profiter de ça parce que la
singularité c'est quelque chose de très
précieux et je vais me servir des mots
de de quelqu'un d'autre que moi
s'appelle jacques prévert qui a écrit un
poème qui m'accompagne depuis très très
longtemps qu est un poème qui a été
écrit pour parler de l'adolescence et
qui moi me parle de singularité et comme
c'est souvent le cas dans les oeuvres
d'art ça échappe à l'intention de son de
son créateur
silence de vie de jacques prévert
je ne veux
en apprendre je ne veux rien comprendre
ni retenir de mort tu vois je ne veux
plus l'entendre ce vacarme sourd et
bruyant de phrases ces deux chiffres de
nombre et l'idée depuis longtemps déjà
même en se taisant la vie chante avec
moi quelque chose de beau je refuse
votre langage
pardon je n'entends plus votre langage
je refuse votre cerveau un autre cerveau
dit l'enfant l'enfant sauvage
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]